La generación de mi madre no participaba en el liderazgo profesional.
Había algunos hombres inspiradores en el camino,
pero ninguno conocía las demandas y presiones a las que me enfrentaba,
presiones que se agudizaron cuando tuve mis dos hijos preciosos.
Y aunque a las mujeres occidentales les encanta darnos consejos
a las pobres mujeres árabes oprimidas,
viven vidas diferentes con diferentes limitaciones.
Las mujeres árabes de mi generación han sido nuestros propios modelos.
Hemos tenido que hacer más malabares que los hombres árabes
y hemos tenido que enfrentar la rigidez cultural más que las mujeres occidentales.
Por eso, me gustaría pensar que las mujeres pobres, oprimidas
tienen algunas lecciones útiles, ganadas con el sudor de compartir,
lecciones que pueden ser útiles
para cualquiera que desee prosperar en el mundo moderno.
Estas son las tres mías.
["Convierte su mierda en tu combustible".]
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Esta palabra todo el mundo la está promocionando como la clave del éxito:
resiliencia.
Pero, ¿qué es exactamente la resiliencia y cómo se desarrolla?
Creo que es la capacidad de convertir la mierda en combustible.
En mi trabajo anterior, mucho antes de mi firma actual,
trabajaba con un hombre que llamaremos Juan.
Hacía equipo con Juan y trabajaba arduamente,
esperando que se diera cuenta de lo buena que era
y me apoyara para hacerme socia de la firma.
Además trabajaba en mis proyectos de consultoría,
escribía apasionadamente sobre el poderío económico de las mujeres.
Un día, presento mi investigación a una sala llena de estudiantes de MBA.
Juan era parte de la audiencia
y escuchaba por primera vez los detalles de mi estudio.
Mientras procedía con mi presentación,
podía ver a Juan con el rabillo del ojo.
Había palidecido
y se había deslizado debajo de su silla en aparente vergüenza.
Terminé mi presentación con una audiencia aplaudiendo
y nos apuramos a salir y a subir al coche.
Allí explotó.
"¡Lo que hiciste es inaceptable!
¡Eres una consultora, no una activista!"
Le dije: "Juan, no lo entiendo.
Presenté un par de índices sobre paridad de género,
y algunas conclusiones sobre el mundo árabe.
Sí, hoy día estamos en la parte inferior del índice,
pero ¿qué dije o presenté que no fuera un hecho?"
A lo que respondió, "Toda la premisa de tu estudio es errónea.
Lo que haces es peligroso y romperá el tejido social de nuestra sociedad".
Hizo una pausa y luego añadió,
"Cuando las mujeres tienen hijos, su lugar es en el hogar".
El tiempo se detuvo por un largo tiempo,
y todo lo que podía pensar y repetir en el caos de mi cerebro era:
"Olvídate de esa asociación, Leila.
Nunca va a pasar".
Me tomó un par de días asimilar este incidente y sus consecuencias,
pero una vez que lo hice, llegué a tres conclusiones.
Uno, esos eran sus problemas,
sus complejos.
Es posible que haya muchos como él en nuestra sociedad,
pero nunca dejaría que sus problemas sean míos.
Dos, que necesitaba otro patrocinador y rápido.
Tengo uno, por cierto, y uno bueno.
Y tres, iba mostrar a Juan lo que las mujeres con niños pueden hacer.
Aplico esta lección igualmente a mi vida personal.
Conforme he progresado en mi carrera,
he recibido muchas palabras de aliento,
pero también he conocido a hombres, mujeres y parejas
que han tenido claramente un problema con que mi marido y yo
hayamos elegido el camino de una pareja de doble carrera.
Así que tienen a esta pareja bien intencionada
que dice directamente en una reunión familiar
o en una reunión de amigos,
vamos, no eres una gran madre,
teniendo en cuenta lo que estás invirtiendo en tu carrera, ¿no?
Mentiría si dijera que estas palabras no duelen.
Mis hijos son lo más preciado para mí,
y la idea de que les podría fallar es intolerable.
Pero justo como hice con Juan,
rápidamente me recordé a mí misma que esos eran sus problemas,
sus complejos.
Así que en lugar de responder,
les di la espalda con una amplia sonrisa
mientras veía el siguiente letrero
con el ojo de mi mente.
[Estar feliz enoja a las personas]
(Aplausos)
Como mujer joven en estas situaciones, hay dos opciones.
Internalizar estos mensajes negativos
que lanzan contra uno
para hacernos sentir como un fracaso,
como si el éxito fuera demasiado difícil de lograr,
o puede optar por ver que la negatividad de los demás es su propio problema,
y transformarlo en su propio combustible personal.
He aprendido a ir siempre por la opción dos,
y he encontrado que me ha fortalecido.
Y es cierto lo que dicen:
el éxito es la mejor venganza.
Algunas mujeres en medio oriente
tienen la suerte de estar casadas con una persona que apoya su carrera.
Corrección: debería decir "tienen la inteligencia"
porque con quién te casas es tu propia elección,
y es mejor casarse con alguien que te apoye si vas a hacer una carrera.
Todavía hoy, el hombre árabe no es un colaborador igualitario en el hogar.
Simplemente no se espera en nuestra sociedad,
e incluso es mal visto como poco viril.
En cuanto a la mujer árabe, nuestra sociedad sigue suponiendo
que su principal fuente de felicidad debe ser la felicidad y la prosperidad
de sus hijos y esposo.
Existe sobre todo para su familia.
Las cosas están cambiando, pero llevará tiempo.
Por ahora, esto significa que la mujer árabe profesional
tiene que mantener de alguna manera el hogar perfecto,
asegurarse de que las necesidades de sus hijos estén atendidas
y gestione su exigente carrera.
Para lograr esto, he aprendido de la manera difícil,
que se deben aplicar los conocimientos profesionales a la vida personal.
Es necesario trabajar la vida.
Así es cómo hago esto en mi vida personal.
Una cosa a saber sobre oriente medio
es que casi todas las familias tienen acceso a ayuda doméstica asequible.
Por lo tanto, el reto es cómo reclutar con eficacia.
Al igual que lo haría en mi vida profesional, baso la selección
de quién me apoyaría con mis hijos mientras estoy en el trabajo
en una referencia fuerte.
Cristina había trabajado durante cuatro años con mi hermana
y la calidad de su trabajo estaba bien clara.
Ella es ahora un miembro integral de la familia,
ha estado con nosotros desde que Alia tenía seis meses.
Se asegura de que la casa funcione sin problemas mientras estoy en el trabajo,
y me aseguro de impulsarla
en las condiciones más óptimas para ella y mis hijos,
justo como lo haría con el mejor talento en el trabajo.
Esta lección se aplica a cualquiera que cuide niños,
sea niñera o enfermera,
niñera a tiempo parcial.
Elegir con mucho cuidado y empoderar.
Si vemos mi calendario,
todos los días laborables
tienen una hora y media de 19:00 a 20:30, hora de EAU
ocupado por "tiempo de la familia".
Este es tiempo sagrado.
He hecho esto desde que Alia era un bebé.
Hago todo lo posible para proteger este momento
para poder estar en casa para pasar tiempo de calidad con mis hijos,
preguntarles acerca de su día,
revisar la tarea, leer un cuento antes de dormir
y darles muchos besos y abrazos.
Si estoy de viaje, cualquiera que sea la zona horaria,
uso Skype para hablar con mis hijos, incluso si estoy muy lejos.
Nuestro hijo Burhan tiene cinco años,
está aprendiendo a leer y a hacer matemáticas básicas.
Aquí hay otra confesión:
He encontrado que nuestra hija es en realidad más exitosa
en enseñarle a él que yo.
(Risas)
Comenzó como un juego, pero a Alia le encanta jugar al maestro con su hermano,
y he visto que estas sesiones mejoran la lectura de Burhan,
aumentan el sentido de la responsabilidad de Alia,
y refuerzan la unión entre ellos,
un ganar ganar en todo.
Las mujeres árabes exitosas que conozco
han encontrado cada una su enfoque único para trabajar su vida
a medida que continúan
con la responsabilidad en el hogar.
Pero esto no se trata solo de sobrevivir en su doble papel
como mujer de carrera y de madre.
También se trata de estar en el presente.
Cuando estoy con mis hijos,
trato de dejar el trabajo fuera de nuestras vidas.
En lugar de preocuparme por los minutos que puedo pasar con ellos diario,
me centro en hacer estos momentos memorables,
momentos en los que veo a mis hijos,
los oigo, conectamos.
["Une fuerzas, no compitas".]
Las mujeres árabes de mi generación no han sido muy visibles
para el ojo público conforme crecían.
Esto explica, creo, en cierta medida,
por qué hay tan pocas mujeres en la política en el mundo árabe.
La ventaja de esto, sin embargo,
es que hemos pasado mucho tiempo
desarrollando una habilidad social detrás de las escenas,
en cafeterías, en las salas de estar,
en el teléfono,
una habilidad social que es muy importante para el éxito:
crear redes.
Yo diría que la mujer árabe promedio
tiene una gran red de amigos y conocidos.
La mayoría son también mujeres.
En occidente, parece que las mujeres ambiciosas a menudo se comparan con otras
con la esperanza de que las vean como la mujer más exitosa en la habitación.
Esto conduce al comportamiento del que se habla
entre las mujeres profesionales.
Si solo hay espacio para una mujer en la parte superior,
entonces no se puede hacer espacio para otros, mucho menos levantarlos.
Las mujeres árabes, en general,
no han caído en esta trampa psicológica.
Frente a una sociedad patriarcal,
han encontrado que al ayudarse uno al otro,
todos se benefician.
En mi trabajo anterior, era la mujer de más alto rango en medio oriente,
uno podría pensar que invertir en la red de mi colegas mujeres
no podría traer muchos beneficios
y que debería invertir mi tiempo
desarrollando mis relaciones con los compañeros y superiores.
Sin embargo, dos de mis grandes saltos vinieron por el apoyo de otras mujeres.
fue la responsable de publicidad quien inicialmente sugirió que
me podrían considerar como un joven líder en el Foro Económico Mundial.
Estaba familiarizada con mis compromisos y mis publicaciones en los medios
y cuando se le preguntó su opinión,
destacó mi nombre.
Una joven consultora, una señora de Arabia y amiga,
me ayudó a vender mi primer proyecto en Arabia Saudita,
un mercado difícil como mujer.
Ella me presentó a un cliente,
y esa presentación resultó en el primer de muchos proyectos para mí en Arabia.
Hoy en día, tengo dos mujeres mayores en mi equipo,
y las veo triunfar como llave de mi propio éxito.
Las mujeres continúan avanzando en el mundo,
no lo suficientemente rápido, pero nos estamos moviendo.
El mundo árabe, también, está progresando, a pesar de muchos reveses recientes.
Solo este año, los EAU nombraron a cinco nuevos ministros femeninos en su gabinete,
para un total de ocho ministras.
Eso es casi el 28 % del gabinete,
y es más de lo que muchos países desarrollados pueden presumir.
Esta es la imagen favorita de mi hija Alia.
Este es el resultado, sin duda, de un gran liderazgo,
pero también es el resultado de las mujeres árabes fuertes
al no darse por vencidas y empujar constantemente los límites.
Es el resultado de la mujer árabe decidiendo todos los días como yo
en convertir la mierda en combustible,
en trabajar su vida para mantener el trabajo de su vida,
y en unir fuerzas y no competir.
Al mirar hacia el futuro,
espero para mi hija cuando ella llegue a esta etapa
en unos 20, 30 años,
en que esté orgullosa tanto de llamarse la hija de su madre
como la hija de su padre.
Mis esperanzas para mi hijo
son que, para entonces, la expresión "hijo de su madre" o "niño de mamá"
haya adquirido un significado completamente diferente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)